blake shelton hilariously pulls the gwen  stefani card on night 2 of The Voice  Blind Auditions I mean if you got it you  got to use it the 40-year old country  singer and his fellow judge and BFF Adam  Levine went head-to-head on Tuesday  night's episode over contestant Ethan  Tucker who sang a reggae inspired  version of Roxanne yes I think that  musically we get along although it  seemed he would go with Adam because of  their mutual tastes and music like Trump  the animal singer with this you may be  wondering how I can help you but I do  have some I'm wondering how I can help I  do have some serious connections in that  reggae ska world these days yes I'm not  afraid to say that I played the Gwen  Stefani card  despite Gwen Stefani no longer being on  the show and Blake and Ethan coming from  completely different musical backgrounds  Stefani clearly had a pull with Ethan  cuz he chose Blake I think I'm gonna  have to pick Blake over here